Oscar was 31, working two jobs with three little kids and a fourth on the way. His living room in Framingham, Massachusetts, a Boston suburb, was covered with toys, and in the kitchen in a corner were some trophies that he won as a bull fighter as a teenager back in Guatemala where he grew up. He'd been in the United States since he was 19, a dozen years.
奥斯卡今年31岁，打着两份工，有三个年幼的孩子，第四个孩子也即将出生。他位于马萨诸塞州弗雷明汉（波士顿郊区）的客厅里堆满了玩具，厨房角落里放着一些奖杯，那是他十几岁时在危地马拉家乡作为斗牛士赢得的。他19岁来到美国，已经待了十二年。
And then, he had a strange phone call. A woman from the public prosecutor's office back in Guatemala was looking for him. Now, he was in the United States illegally. And he worried, could it be about that somehow?
后来，他接到了一个奇怪的电话。危地马拉检察官办公室的一名女子在找他。当时他在美国的身份是非法的。他很担心，这会不会跟那件事有关？
And then, he spoke with this woman. Her name was Sara Romero, and it had nothing to do with that. It was way stranger. She had been looking into a massacre that had happened back in the early 1980s out in the countryside in a tiny town during Guatemala's civil war. And she believed Oscar was one of the survivors.
后来，他与那位名叫萨拉·罗梅罗的女子通了话。这跟那种事无关，但情况更离奇。她一直在调查危地马拉内战期间，80年代初在乡下一个小镇发生的屠杀事件。她认为奥斯卡是幸存者之一。
I was, like, confused. I didn't know what she was talking about. She said, "I know you don't know much about it or you probably don't know anything about it," because I was quiet. I was just listening to what she was saying.
我当时感到很困惑。我不知道她在说什么。她说：“我知道你对此了解不多，或者你可能根本不知道，”因为我当时很安静。我只是在听她说话。
Clearly, they have the wrong person, Oscar thought. He had never been to the little town where this massacre happened. He grew up far away from there. He didn't have any questions about his past. In fact, he had a pretty idyllic childhood.
奥斯卡想，他们肯定找错人了。他从来没去过那个发生屠杀的小镇。他是在离那儿很远的地方长大的。他对自己的过去没有任何疑问。事实上，他有着相当田园诗般的童年。
Yes, his mom had died when he was a baby. Yes, his dad was killed in a truck accident when he was four. But his dad's mom, his grandmother, raised him comfortably. He felt loved.
是的，他母亲在他婴儿时期就去世了。是的，他父亲在他四岁时死于一场卡车事故。但他父亲的母亲，也就是他的祖母，把他抚养长大，生活得很安逸。他感到自己被爱着。
What Sara told Oscar was this. The massacre that she was investigating happen in 1982, when Oscar was three at a village called Dos Erres. More than 200 people were killed there Sara had spoken to several soldiers who were at the massacre, and they told her that two boys had been spared.
萨拉告诉奥斯卡的就是这些。她正在调查的屠杀事件发生在1982年，当时奥斯卡三岁，地点是一个叫多斯埃雷斯（Dos Erres）的村庄。那里有200多人被杀。萨拉采访了几名参加过那次屠杀的士兵，他们告诉她，有两个男孩幸免于难。
One of the boys, the soldier said, was taken by a lieutenant named Oscar Ramirez Ramos. That was Oscar's dad. If Sara's suspicions were right, the man that Oscar thought was his father, the man he had looked up to his entire life, had stolen him from his biological family. His unit killed them and their entire village, Dos Erres. Though, Sara says, when she first contacted Oscar--
那名士兵说，其中一个男孩被一名叫奥斯卡·拉米雷斯·拉莫斯（Oscar Ramirez Ramos）的中尉带走了。那正是奥斯卡的父亲。如果萨拉的怀疑是正确的，那么奥斯卡一直以为的父亲，那个他一生敬仰的人，其实是从他的亲生家庭中把他偷走的。他的部队杀害了他们和整个村庄——多斯埃雷斯。不过，萨拉说，当她第一次联系奥斯卡时——
I told him about the two boys. We felt getting into any specifics about the participation of his dad so as not to hurt his feelings. But I let him know that he could be one of the surviving boys.
我告诉了他关于那两个男孩的事。我们觉得还是不要深入讨论他父亲参与的具体细节，以免伤害他的感情。但我让他知道，他可能就是那两个幸存男孩中的一个。
Well, today on our radio show, we have investigators trying to solve an unsolved murder of more than 200 people from the 1980s in a case that could potentially nudge the political climate of their entire country, and finally hold military officials responsible for massacres that happened there. Just this week, the former president of the country was indicted for genocide in this case.
好吧，今天在我们的广播节目中，我们要介绍一些调查人员，他们试图破解20世纪80年代发生的一起针对200多人的未解谋杀案。这个案件可能会动摇他们整个国家的政治氛围，并最终让军方官员为那里发生的屠杀负责。就在本周，该国前总统因本案被控种族灭绝罪。
And at the center of the whole thing is a guy, Oscar Ramirez, who discovers that everything he thought about his past-- his dad, who he really is-- is all a lie. Oscar's DNA, the DNA of this guy in some Boston suburb, becomes the final piece of evidence in this case. The idea is that if they could just prove with his DNA that he was stolen from Dos Erres, they could link the lieutenant who raised him and his unit to this massacre. For the very first time, they might bring high level soldiers and officers to justice for one of these massacres, which had never been done in Guatemala.
而这一切的核心人物是奥斯卡·拉米雷斯，他发现自己对过去的一切认知——关于他的父亲，关于他真正的身份——全都是谎言。奥斯卡的DNA，这个波士顿郊区男人的DNA，成为了本案最后的关键证据。他们的设想是，如果能用他的DNA证明他是从多斯埃雷斯被偷走的，他们就能将抚养他的中尉及其部队与这场屠杀联系起来。这是危地马拉第一次有可能将高级士兵和军官绳之以法，这在危地马拉此前是从未有过先例的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today is a co-production with ProPublica and the Fundacion MEPI in Mexico City. It has taken months to report and research. It is truly an amazing, heartbreaking tale that takes us deep inside some experiences that I think we all see headlines about that can often seem very far away and hard to imagine the reality of, that, as you'll hear, are not far away at all. We're devoting our entire program to it. Stay with us.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目是与ProPublica和墨西哥城的MEPI基金会联合制作的。我们花了几个月的时间进行报道和研究。这是一个令人惊叹且心碎的故事，它将带我们深入探究一些我们经常在新闻标题中看到、却往往显得遥不可及且难以想象现实的经历，而正如你即将听到的，这些经历其实一点也不遥远。我们将用整期节目来讲述它。请继续收听。
OK, before we dive into this story, just a quick history review. Now, I myself was the kind of insufferable, politically correct person who was obsessed with Latin America back in the 1980s. I called Nicaragua "Neek-ar-ah-wah," and actually went to Nicaragua for a month during the fifth anniversary of the Sandinista revolution. I traveled in Guatemala during the civil war.
好了，在进入故事之前，先快速回顾一下历史。我本人在80年代曾是一个让人无法忍受的、沉迷于拉美政治正确的家伙。我把尼加拉瓜读作“Neek-ar-ah-wah”，甚至在桑地诺革命五周年纪念期间去过尼加拉瓜一个月。内战期间我也去过危地马拉。
You, however, might be what we call a normal person and didn't do any of that. So to provide some context, I turned to Kate Doyle, who's testified as an expert witness in the trials of human rights abuses by senior military officials in Guatemala. She's a senior analyst at a watchdog group in Washington, D.C., called the National Security Archive.
然而，你们可能属于我们所说的正常人，没做过那些事。所以为了提供背景，我请教了凯特·道尔（Kate Doyle），她在危地马拉高级军官侵犯人权案件的审判中担任专家证人。她是华盛顿特区一个名为“国家安全档案馆”的监督组织的高级分析师。
The violence in Guatemala made the country an outlier, because you don't have anything on the scale of what happened in that country in places like Peru or Argentina or Chile.
危地马拉的暴力事件使该国成为一个异类，因为在秘鲁、阿根廷或智利等地，你找不到任何像该国那样规模的事件。
And so when you talk about this, I picture, OK, somewhere in the back of your mind, there's a list of the ranking of most f'ed up countries in the region.
所以当你谈到这个时，我在脑海中勾勒出一份排名名单，列出该地区最糟糕的国家。
Right.
没错。
And is Guatemala number one?
危地马拉是第一名吗？
Guatemala is way up there.
危地马拉名列前茅。
Give me the rankings. OK, so number one f'ed up is?
告诉我排名。那么，最糟糕的第一名是？
Honduras probably right now.
大概是现在的洪都拉斯。
Honduras?
洪都拉斯？
Honduras is bad.
洪都拉斯很糟糕。
OK, and then number two?
那第二名呢？
Guatemala is pretty bad.
危地马拉相当糟糕。
Pretty bad going back decades. Starting in the 1960s, small guerrilla groups challenged what was a corrupt and repressive government. There was also a broader movement calling for political rights, land reform, workers' rights. This always met with brutal violence. Reformers were assassinated. Civilian populations in the countryside were accused of harboring guerrillas and exterminated in the name of anti-communism. This violence peaked in the 1980s.
这种相当糟糕的情况持续了几十年。从20世纪60年代开始，小型游击队组织挑战了一个腐败和压迫性的政府。当时还有一场呼吁政治权利、土地改革和工人权利的广泛运动。这总是遭到残酷的镇压。改革者被暗杀。农村的平民被指责为游击队提供庇护，并以反共的名义遭到灭绝。这种暴力在80年代达到了顶峰。
These were essentially scorched earth operations. Soldiers would sweep through targeted areas. They were using plans drafted by the Army High Command. And they would essentially kill everything in sight.
这基本上是焦土作战。士兵会扫荡目标区域。他们使用的是军队最高指挥部起草的计划，基本上会杀死视线范围内的一切。
She says that what's amazing is the pattern. You see the same techniques again and again. A warning-- this description gets violent. A patrol would enter the community, usually on market day when everybody was gathered.
她说令人震惊的是那种模式。你一遍又一遍地看到相同的手段。警告——接下来的描述会很暴力。巡逻队会进入社区，通常是在大家聚集的集市日。
And they would immediately separate out the men from the women and children. And they would put them into some of the village's biggest buildings, like the school or the church. And then, the soldiers would proceed to destroy everything.
他们会立即把男人和妇女儿童分开。他们把他们关进村里最大的几座建筑里，比如学校或教堂。然后，士兵们就会开始摧毁一切。
They would burn the fields where the villagers grew their food. They would slaughter the animals. They would destroy the houses. They would burn them to the ground. They would bring the men, then, out and execute them.
他们会烧毁村民种植食物的田地。他们会屠宰动物。他们会摧毁房屋，将其烧为平地。然后，他们会把男人们带出来并处决。
They would then take the women and the children. They would rape most of the girl children and the women. And then they would kill them.
然后他们会带走妇女和儿童。他们会强奸大多数女孩和妇女。然后杀掉她们。
This happened in over 600 villages, tens of thousands of people. A truth commission found that the number of Guatemalans killed or disappeared by their own government was over 180,000. And unlike many other Latin American countries, none of the soldiers and leaders who did all this were held accountable.
这种情况发生在600多个村庄，涉及数万人。一个真相委员会发现，被本国政府杀害或失踪的危地马拉人超过18万。与许多其他拉美国家不同，执行这一切的士兵和领导人中没有一个被追究责任。
Many of them transitioned into civilian government. Most of them continued to be very notable, very prominent figures in Guatemalan society.
他们中的许多人转入了文职政府。他们中的大多数人继续在危地马拉社会中成为非常著名、非常显赫的人物。
For years, the government denied the massacres happened at all. Even after a peace treaty with the rebels in 1996, a truth commission was set up but told specifically not to name names, not to gather evidence for trials. No soldier or military leader was brought to justice for the massacres-- until Dos Erres and the investigation into what happened there.
多年来，政府完全否认屠杀事件的发生。甚至在1996年与反政府武装签署和平条约后，虽然成立了真相委员会，但明确要求不得点名，不得为审判收集证据。没有士兵或军事领导人因为这些屠杀被绳之以法——直到多斯埃雷斯事件以及对该事件的调查。
Several people were involved in reporting the story that you're about to hear. There's Sebastian Rotella and Ana Arana. There's our producer, Brian Reed, and Habiba Nosheen. Sometimes, you're going to hear Brian in the tape. Habiba narrates this story. Here she is.
有几个人参与了你即将听到的故事的报道。包括塞巴斯蒂安·罗泰拉（Sebastian Rotella）和安娜·阿拉纳（Ana Arana）。还有我们的制作人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）和哈比巴·诺欣（Habiba Nosheen）。有时，你会在录音中听到布莱恩的声音。哈比巴是这个故事的讲述者。下面有请她。
When investigators started looking into the Dos Erres massacre in the '90s, people trying to uncover the truth about that sort of thing were being killed like an anthropologist, Myrna Mack, who was trying to expose the details of the military's scorched earth campaign and then was stabbed 27 times by a member of the president's intelligence team.
当调查人员在90年代开始调查多斯埃雷斯屠杀案时，试图揭露此类真相的人被杀害了，比如人类学家米尔娜·麦克（Myrna Mack），她试图揭露军队焦土运动的细节，结果被总统情报小组的一名成员刺了27刀。
Or like in 1998 when a Catholic bishop headed a truth commission that concluded that the military was behind the vast majority of the atrocities during the civil war. Just two days after the report came out, he was found bludgeoned to death with a concrete block in his garage.
又或者像1998年，一位天主教主教领导了一个真相委员会，得出的结论是军方是内战期间绝大多数暴行的幕后黑手。报告发布仅两天后，他就被发现死在自己的车库里，被人用混凝土块殴打致死。
But none of this stopped a woman named Aura Elena Farfan when she first started looking into rumors of a secret grave at a place called Dos Erres. Aura looks like someone's grandmother. She's 72 years old with short, graying hair. In 1984, a member of her family was disappeared. Aura suspected the military was behind it, so she and her brother started looking into what happened.
但这一切并没有阻止一个叫奥拉·埃琳娜·法尔凡（Aura Elena Farfan）的女人，当她第一次开始调查关于多斯埃雷斯秘密坟墓的传言时。奥拉看起来像个祖母。她今年72岁，留着灰白的短发。1984年，她的家族中有一人失踪。奥拉怀疑是军方所为，于是她和弟弟开始调查发生了什么。
Two months later, her brother vanished, too. So Aura started an organization to investigate and bring these kinds of cases to justice. And that's how she came across the massacre of Dos Erres.
两个月后，她弟弟也失踪了。于是奥拉成立了一个组织，专门调查这类案件并为受害者寻求正义。她就是这样发现了多斯埃雷斯的屠杀事件。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
At the beginning of 1994, we received reports of bones being found just on the surface of the Earth. And in addition, there were reports of a well.
1994年初，我们收到报告说在地面上发现了骨头。此外，还有关于一口水井的报道。
The well, Aura heard, had bodies inside of it. It was in the jungle, located in what used to be the village of Dos Erres. In 1982, Dos Erres disappeared. One day, the residents were there. The next day, they were nowhere to be found.
奥拉听说，那口井里有尸体。它位于丛林中，就在曾经的多斯埃雷斯村。1982年，多斯埃雷斯消失了。一天，居民们还在那儿。第二天，他们就踪迹全无了。
When Aura heard about the bones, she put together a team of forensic anthropologists. She told my producer, Brian Reed, and me they trekked 7 and 1/2 miles into the jungle.
当奥拉听说骨头的事后，她组织了一支法医人类学团队。她告诉我的制作人布莱恩·里德和我，他们徒步进入丛林七英里半。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
It was desolation. Overgrown weeds, trees, and bushes would cover us. We couldn't see each other. And because we couldn't see each other, just by whistling or yelling we would call on each other.
那是一片荒凉。疯长的杂草、树木和灌木把我们淹没了。我们看不见彼此。因为看不见彼此，我们只能通过吹口哨或大喊来呼唤对方。
Do you remember the moment that you saw the well?
你还记得你看到那口井的那一刻吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I remember it. It was sunk. It sank one meter, or maybe more. It was three meters below. And then, this tree was growing in the well.
我记得。它下陷了。它下陷了一米，或者更多。它在地下三米处。然后，那棵树在井里生长。
They began digging-- one meter, two meters, three meters. Nothing. Day after day, they went back to the well. They invited the local public prosecutor. He came by, looked into the well, told them they wouldn't find anything there but dog bones.
他们开始挖掘——一米、两米、三米。什么都没有。日复一日，他们回到井边。他们邀请了当地的检察官。他过来看了看井里，告诉他们除了狗骨头，他们在那儿什么也找不到。
Finally, they hit four meters. A warning that the next minute or so gets very graphic and probably isn't suitable if you're listening with small children.
最后，他们挖到了四米深。警告：接下来的一分钟左右内容非常生动，如果您带着小孩收听，可能不太合适。
We were able to see the shirt of a small boy, the bones inside. And that made us think that all the inhabitants of Dos Erres were there.
我们看到了一个小男孩的衬衫，里面有骨头。这让我们认为多斯埃雷斯的所有居民都在里面。
So they kept digging. And they found more and more bones, more and more bodies, more and more clothing. They dug up shirts, shoes, hair pins, heart-shaped earrings, boots with silver spurs. In a video they shot at the time, one of the anthropologists stands at the bottom of the well. It's about 40 feet deep. She looks exhausted. There's a tiny skeleton at her feet.
所以他们继续挖掘。他们发现了越来越多的骨头、越来越多的尸体，越来越多的衣服。他们挖出了衬衫、鞋子、发夹、心形耳环、带银刺的靴子。在他们当时拍摄的视频中，一名人类学家站在井底。井深约40英尺。她看起来筋疲力尽。她的脚边有一个小小的骨架。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语]
Just to think that they were thrown from that height into the well, she says, it's hard to even imagine it. It's hard to convince herself of these things. At the end of it all, they found at least 162 bodies plus lots of incomplete remains. 67 of the bodies were victims under 12 years old. Their average age was seven.
她说，只要想到他们是从那么高的地方被扔进井里的，就让人难以想象。这让人很难说服自己相信这些事情。最终，他们至少发现了162具尸体，还有许多不完整的遗骸。其中67具尸体是12岁以下的受害者。他们的平均年龄只有七岁。
Aura and her team wanted to identify these bodies. So they took the remains to the center of the nearest town. They put them together as best they could into skeletons and laid them out. Alongside, they placed the clothing they found in the well next to the body they thought each piece belonged to. Then, they put out an invitation for the community to come and look.
奥拉和她的团队想确认这些遗骸的身份。于是他们把遗骸带到了最近城镇的中心。他们尽可能地把它们拼凑成骨架并排列开来。在旁边，他们摆放了从井里发现的衣服，对应着他们认为属于该死者的骨架。然后，他们向社区发出了邀请，请人们来看。
There is video of this, all the bones and clothing spread out on a concrete floor. People filed by, taking it all in. Some of them recognized clothing worn by their relatives and friends from Dos Erres.
有这段视频，所有的骨头和衣服散落在混凝土的地板上。人们排队走过，看着这一切。其中一些人认出了他们多斯埃雷斯亲友穿过的衣服。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]:
[西班牙语]
But only 10 people came forward to specifically identify relatives. Most were still afraid to admit they knew anyone who had disappeared from Dos Erres. People still remembered how, in 1982 right after the village vanished, family members went to the army commander in the nearest town and asked what happened. This commander, Lieutenant Carlos Antonio Carias, said the guerrillas were responsible. The guerrillas had killed or taken everyone.
但只有10个人站出来确认了亲属身份。大多数人仍然害怕承认他们认识任何从多斯埃雷斯失踪的人。人们仍然记得，1982年村庄消失后不久，家庭成员去附近城镇找军队指挥官询问发生了什么。这位指挥官，卡洛斯·安东尼奥·卡里亚斯（Carlos Antonio Carias）中尉说，是游击队干的。游击队杀死了所有人或带走了所有人。
But he also told family members that if they talked about the incident, even asked about it, they would die-- which just reinforced people's suspicions that the Army was probably behind it. So Aura put herself out there even more to try to get people to talk. She appeared on local media in the province they were in, Peten.
但他也告诉家属，如果他们谈论这件事，甚至哪怕问起，他们就会死——这反而加强了人们对军队是幕后黑手的怀疑。于是，奥拉为了让人们开口，更加抛头露面。她在他们所在的佩滕省的地方媒体上露面。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Each time that we visited in Peten, we took advantage of that moment to speak on the radio, to speak on the TV, to ask people that whoever knew something about Dos Erres to come forward.
每次我们访问佩滕时，都会利用那个机会在电台和电视上发言，恳求那些了解多斯埃雷斯事件的人站出来。
Why were you chuckling just then?
你刚才为什么笑？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Because sometimes I think that I was too daring.
因为有时候我觉得我当时太胆大了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The life of Guatemalans doesn't cost a thing. It's not worth a thing. And just anything could have happened to us.
危地马拉人的命不值钱。一点也不值钱。我们随时可能发生任何事。
Aura was worried about how members of the military might react when they heard her announcements. But she never expected the reaction she got from this guy.
奥拉曾担心军方成员听到她的宣告后会有什么反应。但她没想到会从这个人身上得到这种反应。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I heard this. And I looked at my little children playing. And I decided I'd do this so the same thing would not happen to them, as happened to the children in the massacre at Dos Erres.
我听到了这个。看着我的小孩在玩耍。我决定我要这么做，这样他们就不会遭遇和多斯埃雷斯屠杀中的孩子们一样的命运。
Favio Pinzon Jerez is a former sergeant in the military. And after hearing Aura on the radio, he got on a bus and took the 12-hour ride to Guatemala City. He walked into the UN office and told them he knew what had happened at Dos Erres, because he had taken part in it. He did something no one soldier had ever done in Guatemala-- he confessed.
法比奥·平松·赫雷斯（Favio Pinzon Jerez）是一名军队前中士。在电台听到奥拉的话后，他坐上巴士，经过12个小时的车程来到危地马拉城。他走进联合国办公室，告诉他们他知道多斯埃雷斯发生了什么，因为他参与了其中。他做了一件危地马拉从没有任何士兵做过的事——他坦白了。
Aura went to see Favio in Peten. A UN official trailed her to make sure she was safe.
奥拉去佩滕见了法比奥。一名联合国官员跟随她以确保她的安全。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
We went to his house. We knocked on the door. His children were playing nearby around a table. He says, "Come in, sit down." And so I told him, "I just come from the UN office. And they told me that you wanted to speak to me." He told me, "That's right. I wanted to talk to you because what I have right here, in my heart, I cannot stand it anymore. It's hurting me so much." That's how we talked for four hours. He told me everything that had happened.
我们去了他家。我们敲了门。他的孩子们在附近的桌子周围玩耍。他说：“进来，坐下。”我告诉他：“我刚从联合国办公室回来。他们告诉我你想跟我谈谈。”他告诉我：“没错。我想跟你谈谈，因为我心里这些东西，我再也受不了了。这让我太痛苦了。”就这样我们谈了四个小时。他告诉了我发生的一切。
The story Favio told Aura was deeply upsetting. For nearly 15 years, he'd kept it a secret even from his wife. He told Aura what he and other soldiers had done at Dos Erres.
法比奥告诉奥拉的故事令人深感不安。近15年来，他一直把这个秘密埋在心底，甚至连他妻子都没告诉。他告诉奥拉他和士兵们在多斯埃雷斯干了什么。
Were you mad at him?
你生他的气吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Of course I was. I didn't want to shake his hand.
当然生气。我不想跟他握手。
Why did you not want to shake his hand?
你为什么不想跟他握手？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Because I didn't. It wasn't in me to shake his hand.
因为我不想。我没法和他握手。
After Favio confessed, he convinced another soldier to do the same-- to confess in exchange for immunity. This soldier's name is Cesar Franco Ibanez. They're both in hiding now. We met them secretly at a hotel.
法比奥坦白后，他说服了另一名士兵也这样做——以坦白换取豁免权。这名士兵叫塞萨尔·佛朗哥·伊巴涅斯（Cesar Franco Ibanez）。他们现在都在躲藏。我们在一家酒店秘密见了他们。
The story they told us is disturbing. So again, if you have children with you, it's probably not appropriate for them. Also, if you're sensitive to violence, you may want to tune back in in about 15 minutes.
他们告诉我们的故事令人不安。所以还是要提醒，如果你带着孩子在身边，这可能不适合他们。此外，如果你对暴力敏感，你可能需要过15分钟再回来听。
Favio joined the military when he was 18. His dad worked for the Air Force and got him a job, he says, because he had nothing else to do. He eventually became an Army cook. And in 1979, the Army assigned him to a place called The Schools of the Kaibiles. The Kaibiles are an elite special forces unit. They refer to themselves as killing machines.
法比奥18岁时参军。他说，他父亲为空军工作，给他安排了这份工作，因为他当时没事可做。他最终成了一名陆军厨师。1979年，军队把他分配到一个叫“Kaibiles学校”的地方。Kaibiles是一支精锐特种部队。他们自称为杀人机器。
The school is where they trained in jungle warfare, like how to jump out of planes and moving vehicles. As part of survival training, Favio says, they ate raw snake and dog. He saw people being tortured.
学校里训练的是丛林战，比如如何从飞机和移动的车辆上跳下。法比奥说，作为生存训练的一部分，他们吃生的蛇和狗。他亲眼目睹了人们被折磨。
Favio says he tried to make it as a full-fledged Kaibil.
法比奥说他试图成为一名真正的Kaibil。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I just really only lasted about two weeks. My knees just couldn't take it.
我其实只坚持了两周。我的膝盖受不了。
So that's when you went back to cooking?
所以那是你回到做饭的时候吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well actually, I spent a week sleeping. And then, I went back to cooking.
嗯，事实上，我睡了一个星期。然后，我就回去做饭了。
In 1982, the president of Guatemala, Efrain Rios Montt, formed a secret ops unit of all the instructors at the school. These soldiers were the elite of the elite. Favio was their cook. And their job was to deploy on urgent missions all over the country. One of those was to Dos Erres.
1982年，危地马拉总统埃弗拉因·里奥斯·蒙特（Efrain Rios Montt）从学校的所有教官中组建了一支秘密特种部队。这些士兵是精英中的精英。法比奥是他们的厨师。他们的工作是被派往全国各地执行紧急任务。其中一个任务就是多斯埃雷斯。
It was fall of that year, and the Army had just suffered a humiliating attack from the rebels. Several soldiers had been killed. So commanders called up the special unit. Cesar, the other solder we talked to, told us the story.
那是那年的秋天，军队刚刚遭受了叛军一次羞辱性的袭击。几名士兵被杀。所以指挥官召集了这支特种部队。我们采访的另一名士兵塞萨尔给我们讲了这个故事。
Unlike Favio, Cesar has the bearing of a soldier. He's serious, rarely smiles. They have the same interpreter.
与法比奥不同，塞萨尔有军人的气质。他很严肃，很少微笑。他们共用同一个翻译。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
They said that a unit from our brigade had been ambushed by the guerrillas, and they had taken 21 rifles.
他们说我们旅的一个分队遭到了游击队的伏击，他们抢走了21支步枪。
At the time, the military was waging its scorched earth campaign where they destroy any village they suspected of helping guerrillas, even something as small as giving them some food. In this case, officers told the unit that guerrillas were keeping the rifles in Dos Erres.
当时，军方正在进行焦土作战，他们会摧毁任何被怀疑帮助游击队的村庄，哪怕只是给他们提供一点食物。在这种情况下，军官告诉部队，游击队把步枪藏在多斯埃雷斯。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And they told us that our mission was to recover the 21 rifles that had been taken. And so the plan was we'd go in in the dead of night for a surprise.
他们告诉我们，我们的任务是收回被抢走的21支步枪。计划是我们在深夜进入，进行突袭。
Their strategy was to pretend that they were guerrillas. That would make it easier to sneak in. It would also make it easier to later blame guerrillas for this attack.
他们的策略是伪装成游击队。这样更容易潜入。这也可以让之后更容易把袭击归咎于游击队。
So they disguised themselves. They wore green t-shirts, camouflage pants, and red arm bands. They rode in vegetable trucks that they car jacked off the highway. When they reached Dos Erres at 2:00 in the morning, they found a quiet, peaceful village. Too small, in fact, to even be a full village.
于是他们伪装了起来。他们穿上绿色T恤、迷彩裤，戴上红袖章。他们乘坐从高速公路上劫持的蔬菜车。当他们在凌晨2点到达多斯埃雷斯时，他们发现这是一个安静、祥和的村庄。事实上，它太小了，甚至算不上一个完整的村庄。
Residents were still asleep. They were mostly small time farmers who grew beans, corn, and pineapples. Though when the Kaibiles arrived, Cesar says, they expected something different.
居民们还在睡觉。他们大多是种植豆类、玉米和菠萝的小农户。当Kaibiles部队到达时，塞萨尔说，他们预想的情况完全不同。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Well, we were expecting that they were going to shoot at us because we thought that the people in Dos Erres were all communists. And so were expecting them to attack us. We were waiting for them to attack us with heavy armament. And it didn't happen. Nobody shot at us.
嗯，我们以为他们会向我们开火，因为我们认为多斯埃雷斯的人全都是共产党员。所以我们预料他们会攻击我们。我们等着他们用重武器攻击我们。但并没有发生。没有人向我们开火。
They split off into smaller groups, including an assault group of the fiercest soldiers. Cesar says these were the soldiers who were normally in charge of capturing prisoners, interrogating them, and killing them. Psychopaths, he called them.
他们分成小组，包括一个由最凶残的士兵组成的突击小组。塞萨尔说这些士兵通常负责抓捕囚犯、审问和杀害他们。他称他们为精神病态者。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
This assault group was given the task of getting everybody out of their houses. They put the women and children in the church and the men in the school. And so when they had everyone together, some of the women at the church began to scream for help. And they were raping them. They didn't respect anyone.
这个突击小组的任务是把所有人从屋里带出来。他们把妇女和儿童关进教堂，把男人关进学校。当他们把所有人聚在一起时，教堂里的一些妇女开始尖叫求救。他们在强奸她们。他们不尊重任何人。
Both soldiers, Cesar and Favio, say this was the moment when the mission turned from recovering rifles to something darker. It started with a lieutenant who grabbed a girl and raped her in front of her family. And because he was one of the highest ranking officers, other soldiers started doing it, too, throughout the day. Here's what Favio saw.
两名士兵，塞萨尔和法比奥都说，就在那一刻，任务从收回步枪演变成了更黑暗的事情。起初是一名中尉抓走了一个女孩，并在她家人面前强奸了她。由于他是最高军衔的军官之一，其他士兵也开始效仿，整整一天都是如此。法比奥看到了这些。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
There was a girl about 12 years old. And a guy grabbed her by her hair and dragged her along. And there in the little field to the side, that's where he raped her.
有一个女孩大约12岁。有个家伙抓着她的头发把她拖走。在那边的小田地里，他强奸了她。
One group of soldiers, including Cesar, was ordered to guard the perimeter of the village. People could enter, but no one could go out. Others, including Favio, were ordered to start bringing people from the church and the school to a nearby well.
包括塞萨尔在内的一组士兵被命令守卫村庄边缘。人可以进去，但没有人能出去。包括法比奥在内的其他人则被命令开始把人从教堂和学校带到附近的一口井里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The first massacre was of a baby. I heard crying. And I looked. And I saw Gilberto Jordan and Manuel Pop Sun carrying the baby. They threw the baby alive into the well. And that's the way the massacre began. The first were the children.
第一次屠杀是一个婴儿。我听到了哭声。我看了看。我看到吉尔伯托·乔丹（Gilberto Jordan）和曼努埃尔·波普·孙（Manuel Pop Sun）抱着那个婴儿。他们把活着的婴儿扔进了井里。屠杀就是这样开始的。最先是孩子们。
It was like an assembly line. One by one, soldiers grabbed villagers, blindfolded them, and dragged them to the edge of the well. Along the way, many of the women were raped. This is Cesar. He brought people to the well, too.
这就像一条流水线。士兵们一个接一个地抓住村民，蒙住他们的眼睛，把他们拖到井边。在路上，许多妇女遭到强奸。这是塞萨尔。他也带人去了井边。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
And as they were brought to the well, they were asked, "Where are the rifles?" They said nothing about rifles. And they were hit on the back of the head with a sledgehammer and thrown in the well.
当他们被带到井边时，他们被问到：“步枪在哪里？”他们对步枪只字未提。然后他们的后脑勺被大锤猛击，被扔进了井里。
Did they ensure that they were killed before they were thrown in the well?
他们有没有确保在把人扔进井里之前先杀死他们？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
No. People fell into the well. Then, all of a sudden, they reacted. They screamed.
没有。人们掉进井里。然后，突然之间，他们有了反应。他们尖叫。
How many people did you bring to the well? Did you bring to their death?
你带了多少人到井边？你带了多少人走向死亡？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
About 15, around 15.
大概15个，15个左右。
Were you ever asked to kill anyone?
有人要求你去杀人吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Yes, when I took the first person to the well, Lieutenant Rivera told me to throw the person in the well. He did it so that we'd all be implicated in what happened.
是的，当我带第一个人到井边时，里维拉中尉让我把那个人扔进井里。他这么做是为了让我们所有人都卷入发生的事情中。
What would have happened if you said no?
如果你拒绝会发生什么？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
They would have killed us.
他们会杀了我们。
Incredibly, one person managed to escape from all this. He was 11 years old. His name is Salome Armando Hernandez. And he didn't live in Dos Erres. He and his brother showed up later in the morning to visit their uncle.
令人难以置信的是，有一个人成功从这场屠杀中逃脱。他当时11岁。他的名字叫萨洛姆·阿曼多·埃尔南德斯（Salome Armando Hernandez）。他不住在多斯埃雷斯。他和哥哥那天早上晚些时候去探望叔叔。
By sundown, the well was filled with bodies. And soldiers forced a group of women and children, including Salome, out of the church where they had been held, put them in a line, and led them to the forest. Some women carried their children. Some were pregnant. We talked to Salome in Guatemala City. He's 42 now.
日落时分，水井被尸体填满了。士兵们强迫一群妇女和儿童，包括萨洛姆，走出他们被关押的教堂，把他们排成一行，带进了森林。一些妇女抱着孩子。有些妇女怀孕了。我们在危地马拉城采访了萨洛姆。他现在42岁。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
All the women were resisting. They didn't want to go. So the soldiers started pushing and beating them. I remember one of the women saying, "We're not dogs for you to kill us in the field. We know that you're going to kill us. Why don't you kill us right here?" That's when I decided to run.
所有的妇女都在反抗。她们不想走。所以士兵们开始推搡和殴打她们。我记得其中一个妇女说：“我们不是狗，不能让你们在田野里杀掉。我们知道你们要杀了我们。为什么不就在这儿杀了我们？”就在那时，我决定跑。
Salome waited for a soldier to turn away. And then, he sprinted into the woods. He ducked behind a tree trunk and hid. The soldier fired a shot in his direction. He fired again. Salome didn't move.
萨洛姆等着士兵转过头去。然后，他冲进了树林。他躲在一根树干后藏了起来。那名士兵朝他的方向开了一枪。又开了一枪。萨洛姆一动不动。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I was very scared. I was trembling. And then I saw them gathering the women. And they took several steps back. And they started firing, shooting the women. And you could hear all the women in mourning. They were screaming. And then you could still hear some of them wounded. But they were still alive. And after that, you could hear some solid shots like they were killing them one by one, the ones that were still alive.
我很害怕。我在发抖。然后我看到他们把妇女集合起来。他们向后退了几步。他们开始扫射，枪杀那些妇女。你可以听到所有妇女在哀号。她们在尖叫。然后你还能听到一些受伤者的声音。但她们还活着。在那之后，你能听到一些零星的枪声，就像他们一个个在杀死那些还活着的人。
At the end of it all, the entire village was wiped out. No rifles were ever found. Salome escaped. And according to Favio and Cesar, this patrol of killers spared just two other people, both young boys with light skin and green eyes. Three months later, the second in command of the squad that wiped out Dos Erres, Lieutenant Oscar Ramirez Ramos, showed up at his mother's house with a three-year-old boy and a fake birth certificate. He introduced him to his family as his son.
最终，整个村庄被抹平了。没有找到任何步枪。萨洛姆逃脱了。根据法比奥和塞萨尔的说法，这支杀手巡逻队只放过了另外两个人，都是皮肤白皙、长着绿眼睛的小男孩。三个月后，抹平多斯埃雷斯的那个小队的二把手，奥斯卡·拉米雷斯·拉莫斯中尉，带着一个三岁男孩和一份伪造的出生证明出现在他母亲家。他向家人介绍他是自己的儿子。
In 1996, the Dos Erres case landed on the desk of Sara Romero, the assistant prosecutor who contacted Oscar. She was a rookie, just a year out of law school. And she had almost no support from her own ministry. This is the same ministry that, at one point, had dismissed the remains at Dos Erres as dog bones. So the case wasn't exactly a priority for them. It was just Sara and one other colleague working it on their own. They had almost nothing to go on. They couldn't even prove the military was behind the massacre, never mind which unit of the military or which members in the unit.
1996年，多斯埃雷斯案放到了萨拉·罗梅罗的办公桌上，这位助理检察官联系了奥斯卡。她当时是个新人，刚从法学院毕业一年。她的部门几乎没给她任何支持。正是同一个部门，曾一度将多斯埃雷斯的遗骸斥为狗骨头。所以这个案子对他们来说并不是什么优先事项。只有萨拉和另一位同事在独立运作。他们几乎毫无头绪。他们甚至无法证明军队是屠杀的幕后黑手，更别提是哪个部队或部队中的哪些成员了。
So when Favio and Cesar came forward, it was an unprecedented break. Sara's office had to create a witness protection program specifically for the two of them, because before that they hadn't had any witnesses to protect.
所以当法比奥和塞萨尔站出来时，这是一个前所未有的突破。萨拉的办公室不得不专门为他们两人设立了一个证人保护计划，因为在此之前他们根本没有需要保护的证人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The next step was to confirm all the pieces of information that the Kaibil witnesses had given.
下一步是证实Kaibil证人提供的所有信息片段。
Remember, Sara was trying to do something that had never been done before in Guatemala. There hadn't been a single trial against members of the military for crimes they had committed during the war. So she knew if she was going to build a case that would win, she needed more evidence.
记住，萨拉试图在危地马拉做一件前所未有的事情。在此之前，没有针对任何军方成员因战时罪行进行的审判。所以她知道，如果她想建立一个能胜诉的案子，她需要更多证据。
She didn't have names for most of the victims. So she poked around until she found a teacher who lived near Dos Erres who had taught some of the children from the village back in the '80s. Sara asked her to remember, as best she could, the names of her former students. Sara used those names to track down relatives.
她没有大多数受害者的名字。所以她四处打听，直到找到了一位住在多斯埃雷斯附近的老师，她在80年代曾教过村里的一些孩子。萨拉请她尽可能回忆起她以前学生的名字。萨拉利用这些名字追踪到了受害者的亲属。
Because of Favio and Cesar, Sara did have the names of the other Kaibiles who had been at the massacre. So she started tracking them down, too, which meant walking up to their doorsteps and confronting them face to face, including a Kaibil who took one of the green-eyed boys who was spared that day. The Kaibil's name was Santos Lopez Alonzo.
由于法比奥和塞萨尔，萨拉确实掌握了当时在屠杀现场的其他Kaibiles士兵的名字。所以她也开始追踪他们，这意味着走到他们门口与他们面对面对质，包括一名在那天带走了一名绿眼男孩的Kaibil。那个Kaibil的名字叫桑托斯·洛佩斯·阿隆佐（Santos Lopez Alonzo）。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I had never faced a Kaibil before. And because of the description that I had of the Kaibiles, I thought that he was going to be armed, and that if he knew that I knew something about Dos Erres he was going to shoot at me. Or perhaps he was going to capture us and torture us.
我以前从未面对过Kaibil。由于我对Kaibiles的描述，我以为他会带着武器，而且如果他知道我知道一些关于多斯埃雷斯的事，他就会向我开枪。或者他可能会抓走我们并折磨我们。
Were you armed?
你带着武器吗？
No.
没有。
Your colleague?
你的同事呢？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
No, he wasn't either. None of us was armed.
没有，他也没有。我们都没带武器。
Sara and her partner had to leave their car on the road and walk through the woods to Lopez Alonzo's house. They told their driver to call the police if they didn't come back.
萨拉和她的搭档不得不把车停在路边，步行穿过树林前往洛佩斯·阿隆佐的家。他们告诉司机如果他们没回来就报警。
They approached the house. And there was Lopez Alonzo, lying in a hammock.
他们走近房子。洛佩斯·阿隆佐正躺在吊床上。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
When I saw him, I wasn't fearful at all.
当我看到他时，我一点也不害怕。
Why not?
为什么不害怕？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Because he looked like a campesino, like a peasant. He was just a simple person, a person without education and not as ferocious as I imagined him to be.
因为他看起来像个坎佩西诺，像个农民。他只是一个简单的人，一个没有受过教育的人，不像我想象中那么凶猛。
Lopez Alonzo was polite and invited them in. At first, he wouldn't talk about Dos Erres. Then, Sara told him that two soldiers from his squad had already come forward. And he started telling the truth. "My oldest son, Ramiro, has a sad story," he told them. And he confessed to taking him from Dos Erres.
洛佩斯·阿隆佐很有礼貌，请他们进去。起初，他不愿谈论多斯埃雷斯。然后，萨拉告诉他，他小队里的两名士兵已经站出来了。他开始说实话。“我的长子拉米罗，有一个悲伤的故事，”他告诉他们。他承认从多斯埃雷斯带走了他。
When Sara tracked Ramiro down, he was serving in the military that had killed his family. The fact that he existed and that he was saved by one of the Kaibiles, and raised by one of the Kaibiles, made it nearly impossible for the Kaibiles to deny their involvement in the massacre.
当萨拉找到拉米罗时，他正在杀害他家人的军队中服役。他存在的事实，以及他被其中一名Kaibiles拯救并抚养长大，使得Kaibiles几乎无法否认他们参与了屠杀。
At the same time, Sara started to look for the other boy who Favio and Cesar told her was spared. But it wasn't as easy. The soldier who allegedly took him was dead. That soldier's mother who supposedly raised the boy was also dead. The soldier's brother refused to talk. His sister was also reluctant, but told Sara that in 1983, he did indeed come home with a three-year-old boy. The boy was chubby with broken teeth. His name was Oscar.
与此同时，萨拉开始寻找法比奥和塞萨尔告诉她的那个被放过的男孩。但没那么容易。据称带走他的那名士兵已经死了。据说抚养那个男孩的士兵的母亲也死了。那名士兵的兄弟拒绝交谈。他的姐妹也很不情愿，但告诉萨拉，1983年，他确实带回家了一个三岁的男孩。那个男孩胖乎乎的，牙齿烂了。他的名字叫奥斯卡。
After his grandma died, he'd moved to the US illegally. She told Sara she had no way to reach him. So Sara stopped looking for 10 years.
在祖母去世后，他非法移民到了美国。她告诉萨拉，她没办法联系到他。所以萨拉停止寻找了10年。
Coming up, and the Oscar goes to-- where did he go to? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，奥斯卡要去哪儿——请稍后收听芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. If you're just tuning in, we're devoting our entire program today to a massacre of a village in Guatemala called Dos Erres in 1982, and the attempt to bring the killers to justice, which took years. One of the ways that we know about what happened at Dos Erres is from secret cables that have been declassified that were sent back and forth between the United States embassy in Guatemala and Washington, D.C.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。如果你刚加入节目，我们今天用整期节目来讲述1982年危地马拉一个叫多斯埃雷斯的村庄发生的屠杀事件，以及为将杀人凶手绳之以法所做的努力，这花费了多年时间。我们了解多斯埃雷斯发生的事情的方法之一，是通过一些已解密的机密电报，这些电报是在美国驻危地马拉大使馆和华盛顿特区之间往来发送的。
These cables show that back in 1981 and '82, embassy officials heard lots of reports about the Army massacring whole villages throughout Guatemala, which they dismissed until finally, in 1982, at the urging of the State Department back in Washington they got in a helicopter to see for themselves if the stories were true. And this is just a coincidence-- the site that they happened to investigate was Dos Erres.
这些电报显示，早在1981年和82年，大使馆官员就听到了大量关于军队在危地马拉各地屠杀整个村庄的报告，他们对此不予理会，直到最后在1982年，在华盛顿国务院的敦促下，他们乘坐直升机去亲眼核实这些故事是否属实。这纯属巧合——他们碰巧调查的地点就是多斯埃雷斯。
They flew their helicopter low over the village. They saw the burned-out houses. They looked for but found no survivors. They landed in a nearby town where the mayor told them that the disappearance of every man, woman, and child from Dos Erres was simply a mystery. The United States concluded that the Guatemalan Army was responsible. But they kept this a secret, didn't discuss it publicly. And for years afterwards, the killings continued. And the US knew about it but stood by.
他们驾驶直升机在村庄上方低空飞行。他们看到了烧毁的房屋。他们寻找幸存者却一无所获。他们降落在附近的一个城镇，镇长告诉他们，多斯埃雷斯每一个男人、妇女和孩子的失踪纯粹是一个谜。美国得出的结论是，危地马拉军队负有责任。但他们对此保密，没有公开讨论。此后多年，杀戮仍在继续。美国知道这一点，但袖手旁观。
Before the break, you heard about how Sara Romero started her investigation, how she found one of the two boys who'd been taken from the village but couldn't find Oscar. She had enough evidence to start trying the case, though, and got arrest warrants for 17 members of the Army squad that was at Dos Erres. And then, nothing happened for nearly 10 years.
在广告前，你听到了萨拉·罗梅罗是如何开始调查的，她是如何找到从村里带走的两个男孩之一，但没能找到奥斯卡。不过，她有足够的证据开始尝试起诉此案，并对当时在多斯埃雷斯的陆军小队的17名成员发出了逮捕令。然后，近10年什么也没发生。
The soldiers filed motions and appeals and stalled the case before it ever got started in the Guatemalan court system. Finally, the Interamerican Court of Human Rights looked at what was going on and declared that these appeals were paralyzing justice and ordered Guatemala to bring the soldiers to trial. And that is where our story picks up, with Sara Romero still working on the case 13 years after she started it. Habiba Nosheen takes it from here.
士兵们提出了动议和上诉，在案件进入危地马拉司法系统之前就将其停滞。最后，美洲人权法院审视了正在发生的情况，宣布这些上诉正在瘫痪司法，并命令危地马拉审判这些士兵。我们的故事就是从这里开始的，萨拉·罗梅罗在她开始调查13年后仍在处理这个案子。哈比巴·诺欣从这里开始讲述。
Finally the case was moving forward, and the judge ordered the investigators to do a bunch of things including find Oscar, the green-eyed boy who had been abducted from Dos Erres who they still hadn't located. So Sara got back to work.
案件终于有了进展，法官下令调查人员做许多事情，包括找到奥斯卡，那个从多斯埃雷斯被绑架的绿眼男孩，他们还没找到他。于是萨拉重新投入工作。
She traveled back up to Oscar's hometown where she'd gone looking for him 10 years before. Back then, Oscar's uncle had stonewalled her. He refused to tell her anything about his nephew.
她回到了奥斯卡的家乡，10年前她曾去那里找过他。当时，奥斯卡的叔叔对她百般阻挠。他拒绝告诉她关于他侄子的任何事。
This time, Sara squeezed a bit more out of him. He gave her two pieces of information-- that Oscar's girlfriend was from a nearby town and that her nickname was La Flaca, the skinny one. Sara went to the town, asked around about La Flaca, located her parents. And that's how she tracked down La Flaca and Oscar in Massachusetts and convinced Oscar to take a DNA test to see if he was actually a survivor from Dos Erres.
这一次，萨拉从他那里挤出了一些信息。他给了她两个线索——奥斯卡的女友来自附近的一个城镇，她的绰号叫“La Flaca”（瘦子）。萨拉去了那个镇，打听关于La Flaca的消息，找到了她的父母。她就是这样追踪到马萨诸塞州的La Flaca和奥斯卡，并说服奥斯卡做了一次DNA测试，看看他是否真的是多斯埃雷斯的幸存者。
Fredy Peccerelli, the forensic scientist who was working the case, was excited at the prospect. Usually, he's dealing with dead bodies, people who've been assassinated or massacred.
负责此案的法医科学家弗雷迪·佩切里（Fredy Peccerelli）对此感到兴奋。通常情况下，他面对的都是死人，那些被暗杀或屠杀的人。
To actually be able to talk to one of the people that we're looking for is a privilege that I've never felt before.
能够真正与我们要寻找的人交谈，是一种我从未有过的特权。
In June, 2011, Fredy took a swab of Oscar's saliva, his DNA, back to Guatemala and ran a series of tests. One was against Ramiro, the other green-eyed boy who was taken from the massacre to see if Ramiro was Oscar's brother. They also tested Oscar's DNA against the DNA of other people who were related to the victims of Dos Erres.
2011年6月，弗雷迪采集了奥斯卡的唾液拭子，即他的DNA，带回危地马拉并进行了一系列测试。其中一项是针对拉米罗，那个在屠杀中被带走的另一个绿眼男孩，看看拉米罗是否是奥斯卡的兄弟。他们还将奥斯卡的DNA与其他与多斯埃雷斯受害者有亲属关系的人的DNA进行了对比。
On a Sunday night in August, Fredy called Oscar with the results.
8月的一个周日晚上，弗雷迪打电话告诉奥斯卡结果。
I said, you know, remember that test we did?
我说，你知道，记得我们做的那个测试吗？
So at that point, I was a little bit nervous. You never know.
那时，我有点紧张。你永远不知道结果。
And I told him that I had the news. The news is that Ramiro is not your brother.
我告诉他我有了消息。消息就是拉米罗不是你的兄弟。
He told me that we weren't brothers. I said, "I knew it! I knew that wasn't true!" He says, "Yes, but I haven't finished yet. You guys are not brothers. But we compared with other people's. And we found that you have a father." I said, "What are you talking about?" "It's your father. We found your father," he said. "And you are one of the survivors."
他告诉我我们不是兄弟。我说：“我早知道！我就知道那不是真的！”他说：“是的，但我还没说完。你们不是兄弟。但我们与其他人的进行了比较。我们发现你有一个父亲。”我说：“你在说什么？”他说：“那是你的父亲。我们找到了你的父亲。”他说：“你是一名幸存者。”
I just told him. "Your father's not who you think he is. The guy who you think is your father is not your father. Your father is alive. His name is Tranquilino. And he's old, but he's alive."
我直接告诉了他。“你的父亲不是你以为的那个人。你以为是你父亲的那个人不是你父亲。你的父亲还活着。他叫特兰基利诺（Tranquilino）。他年纪大了，但他还活着。”
Yes, that's right. Fredy's team matched Oscar to his biological father. And that biological father is alive. He survived. Aura found him as part of her ongoing search for anyone related to the victims of Dos Erres.
是的，没错。弗雷迪的团队将奥斯卡与他的生父进行了匹配。而且那位生父还活着。他幸存了下来。奥拉在寻找多斯埃雷斯受害者亲属的过程中找到了他。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
My name is Tranquilino Castaneda Valenzuela.
我的名字是特兰基利诺·卡斯塔涅达·巴伦苏埃拉（Tranquilino Castaneda Valenzuela）。
You hardly need a DNA test to know that Tranquilino is Oscar's dad. The resemblance is striking. Both have green eyes and curly hair. They're both thin. Tranquilino is 70, and he limps when he walks. When we met him, he wore a white cowboy hat and carried two machetes.
你几乎不需要DNA测试就知道特兰基利诺是奥斯卡的父亲。长相惊人地相似。两人都有绿眼睛和卷发。他们都很瘦。特兰基利诺今年70岁，走路一瘸一拐。当我们见到他时，他戴着一顶白色牛仔帽，带着两把砍刀。
Tranquilino's pregnant wife was killed at Dos Erres, along with all of his children-- nine of them. Or so he thought.
特兰基利诺怀孕的妻子在多斯埃雷斯遇害，和他所有的孩子——九个孩子一起。或者他是这么认为的。
For 30 years, he's lived alone in the jungle. He never remarried after the massacre, never had another child. And in the middle of our interview, Tranquilino interrupted with a request.
30年来，他一直独自生活在丛林中。屠杀后他从未再婚，也没有再生孩子。在采访过程中，特兰基利诺打断了我们并提出了一个请求。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Can I give the name of my children?
我能说出我孩子们的名字吗？
Of course.
当然可以。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
My first born was Esther Castaneda. Second one was Etelvina. Enma was the third. After that was Maribel. She was around 13 when she died. Then, it was Luz Antonio, part of my sons. Then, it was Cesar. Cesar was seven years old. Then, two other girls, Odilia and Rosalba.
我的长子是埃丝特·卡斯塔涅达（Esther Castaneda）。第二个是埃特尔维娜（Etelvina）。恩玛（Enma）是第三个。之后是玛丽贝尔（Maribel）。她死的时候大约13岁。然后是卢斯·安东尼奥（Luz Antonio），我的儿子之一。然后是塞萨尔（Cesar）。塞萨尔当时七岁。然后是另外两个女孩，奥迪利亚（Odilia）和罗莎尔芭（Rosalba）。
Anyone else?
还有别人吗？
Si, Alfredo.
是的，阿尔弗雷多（Alfredo）。
Alfredo was Oscar's given name.
阿尔弗雷多是奥斯卡的原名。
Tranquilino was out of town when Dos Erres happened visiting relatives. When he learned about the massacre, that everyone including his wife and kids had been killed--
多斯埃雷斯事件发生时，特兰基利诺刚好不在城里去探亲了。当他得知屠杀事件，得知包括他妻子和孩子在内的所有人都被杀害后——
Ha, ha, ha. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
哈哈。 [西班牙语]
I got all crazy. I really can't put into words. But I felt like I was stupid, dumb. I really thought I was becoming mad.
我疯了。我真的无法用言语表达。但我感觉自己很蠢，很笨。我真的觉得我快疯了。
Tranquilino told us that after that, he just couldn't sleep. He would stay up night after night patrolling his house. He says he started to lose his mind. He would forget simple things, like which turn to take to get to work. His head dropped constantly.
特兰基利诺告诉我们，在那之后，他根本睡不着觉。他会整晚整晚地守在屋里巡逻。他说他开始失去理智。他会忘记简单的事情，比如去上班该转哪个弯。他的头总是垂着。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Listen, I started to drink. I was really, really deep into drinking. It was just really, really deep, because I was sad. I thought I could drown all my sorrows. But then I figure out that my sorrows could swim.
听着，我开始喝酒。我真的沉溺于酗酒之中。那真的很深，因为我很悲伤。我以为我可以淹没我所有的悲伤。但后来我发现，我的悲伤会游泳。
When I met Tranquilino, as soon as he leaned in to say hello, I could tell he'd been drinking. He told me it's still hard for him to talk about Dos Erres without a drink. After 20 minutes, he broke down and said he couldn't continue.
当我见到特兰基利诺时，他一俯身打招呼，我就能看出他喝了酒。他告诉我，如果不喝点酒，他还是很难谈论多斯埃雷斯。20分钟后，他崩溃了，说他无法继续了。
Fredy and Aura told us what it was like when they revealed the news to him that one of his children, his son Oscar, was still alive. They asked Tranquilino to come to Guatemala City. They needed to see him in person.
弗雷迪和奥拉告诉我们，当他们告诉他他的一个孩子，他的儿子奥斯卡还活着时，是什么样的情景。他们要求特兰基利诺来到危地马拉城。他们需要亲自见到他。
Well, he hadn't been told because he's old. He's like 75. You want to be careful with how you deal with this information. So when he was told, I had a doctor standing by just in case he had a heart attack.
嗯，他还没被告知，因为他年纪大了。他大概75岁。处理这些信息时你必须小心。所以当告诉他时，我准备了一名医生，以防他心脏病发作。
Really?
真的吗？
Oh, yeah. I was afraid that he might be too excited about it or something.
哦，是的。我担心他可能会对此太兴奋或什么的。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
He was told that Oscar had been found, that a DNA test had been conducted, and that the results showed with 95% certainty that it was a match. And he would take his hat off, scratch his head, laugh, cry. He didn't know what to do, because he wouldn't believe us. He felt that all his children were dead.
有人告诉他奥斯卡被找到了，他们进行了DNA测试，结果显示有95%的确定性是匹配的。他摘下帽子，抓抓头，笑，哭。他不知道该怎么办，因为他不相信我们。他觉得他所有的孩子都死了。
What was he saying?
他说什么了吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
"Incredible, incredible, incredible!"
“不可思议，不可思议，不可思议！”
Here's how Tranquilino remembers it. He has a different interpreter.
这是特兰基利诺的记忆。他换了一个翻译。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
First when they told me, I wasn't happy. I was sad somehow, and then in a bit of a shock. And I remember that because they had to give me some hard liquor for me to come back to my senses, because I was in a bit of a shock.
刚开始他们告诉我时，我不高兴。我有点悲伤，然后有点震惊。我记得是因为他们不得不给我灌些烈酒让我清醒过来，因为我当时有点震惊。
If that wasn't enough to handle, there was more. One of the anthropologists walked in with a laptop. She turned on Skype. And there, on the screen, sitting in Massachusetts, was Oscar.
如果这还不够处理，还有更多。一名人类学家带着一台笔记本电脑走进来。她打开了Skype。屏幕上，在马萨诸塞州坐着的，正是奥斯卡。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
We were there talking. She pulled my chair. She put it next to her. She grabbed me hard. And then, she said, "Do you know the person, the young man on the screen?" And I said, "No, I don't know who that is." And then, she said, "It's your son." I said, "Not him." And then, I couldn't speak anymore. I couldn't speak anymore.
我们在那里谈话。她拉过我的椅子。把它放在她旁边。她紧紧抓住我。然后，她说：“你认识屏幕上那个年轻人吗？”我说：“不，我不知道那是谁。”然后，她说：“那是你的儿子。”我说：“不是他。”然后，我就再说不出话来了。我再也说不出话来了。
When we first see each other, he couldn't talk. He was just crying. And he said, "I can't talk."
当我们第一次见到对方时，他没法说话。他只是在哭。他说：“我没法说话。”
Oscar just sat there looking at Tranquilino. He didn't know what to say. Oscar was just three when he was taken from Dos Erres. Seeing this man triggered nothing for him, no memories. The first thought that he had was that Tranquilino looked really old. It was hard to believe that this was his father. Then, Tranquilino spoke.
奥斯卡只是坐在那儿看着特兰基利诺。他不知道该说什么。奥斯卡从多斯埃雷斯被带走时才三岁。看到这个人对他没触发任何东西，没有记忆。他脑海中的第一个念头是特兰基利诺看起来真的很老。很难相信这就是他的父亲。然后，特兰基利诺开口了。
He said, "Alfredo." That was the first word that he said, "Alfredo." I said, "Yes, yes, I'm Alfredo."
他说，“阿尔弗雷多”。那是他说的第一个词，“阿尔弗雷多”。我说：“是的，是的，我是阿尔弗雷多。”
That name was familiar to Oscar because it's his middle name. The lieutenant kept it for him. He also kept Oscar's original last name, which is Tranquilino's last name, Castaneda. So Oscar realized that his full name, Oscar Alfredo Ramirez Castaneda, is a combination of his biological dad's name and his Kaibil dad's name.
这个名字对奥斯卡很熟悉，因为那是他的中间名。那位中尉为他保留了这个名字。他还保留了奥斯卡的原始姓氏，也就是特兰基利诺的姓氏，卡斯塔涅达。所以奥斯卡意识到，他的全名，奥斯卡·阿尔弗雷多·拉米雷斯·卡斯塔涅达，是他亲生父亲名字和他Kaibil养父名字的结合体。
Tranquilino kept talking. He told Oscar that he was chubby as a kid, which was true. Oscar was chubby as a kid. Tranquilino told him he used to boss around his siblings even though they were older than him. To this day, Oscar says, that's still true. He is bossy. But the thing that really hit Oscar in the gut was something that was a mystery to him as a little kid.
特兰基利诺继续说。他告诉奥斯卡他小时候胖乎乎的，这是真的。奥斯卡小时候确实很胖。特兰基利诺告诉他，他小时候经常对他兄弟姐妹指手画脚，尽管他们比他大。直到今天，奥斯卡说，这一点依然是真的。他很专横。但真正让奥斯卡感触最深的是一件事，那曾是他小时候的一个谜。
He told me that I didn't have my teeth. And that was true. I didn't have my teeth for a long time.
他告诉我我小时候没牙。那是真的。很长一段时间我都没有牙齿。
Until he was eight or nine, he was missing a bunch of teeth. He says he looked like Dracula. Tranquilino told him his teeth had been rotten when he was young, so they had to pull them out.
直到八九岁时，他还没长出好几颗牙。他说他看起来像德古拉。特兰基利诺告诉他，他小时候牙齿都烂了，所以不得不拔掉。
When he said that, what went off in your head?
当他说那件事时，你脑海中冒出了什么？
Then I started to, you know-- suddenly, this is true. This is really happening.
然后我开始，你知道——突然间，这是真的。这真的正在发生。
I was right there. I was on the screen with them.
我当时就在那里。我和他们一起在屏幕上。
Here's Fredy.
这是弗雷迪。
We were all crying. There wasn't a person in that room that wasn't crying. Everybody-- I don't know. It was amazing. It was one of the most fulfilling things I've done in my life.
我们都在哭。那个房间里没有一个人没在哭。每个人——我不知道。太神奇了。这是我一生中做过的最令人满足的事情之一。
But the happy ending for Fredy and Aura and Sara didn't feel that way for Oscar. Oscar says it's hard to describe how he felt.
但对弗雷迪、奥拉和萨拉来说的美好结局，对奥斯卡来说却并非如此。奥斯卡说很难描述他的感受。
I don't even know what to tell you. I think blank. Like, what could I say? I was happy. I was more happy than sad. I didn't know what to think about it, you know what I mean? My mind was just blank.
我甚至不知道该告诉你什么。我想是空白。就像，我能说什么呢？我很高兴。我高兴多过悲伤。我不知道该想什么，你明白我的意思吗？我的脑子一片空白。
The difficult thing for Oscar is that he really loves the family that raised him. He wasn't treated the way other children who were stolen from massacres were often treated. Ramiro, for instance, the other boy who was taken from Dos Erres, he was treated horribly growing up, beaten and used almost like a servant. But for Oscar, there's no one to easily hate. His whole life, he's looked up to Ramirez Ramos, the man he thought was his father.
对奥斯卡来说困难的是，他真的很爱抚养他长大的家人。他并没有受到那些从屠杀中被偷走的孩子通常所受到的那种对待。比如拉米罗，那个从多斯埃雷斯被带走的另一个男孩，他在成长过程中受到了可怕的对待，经常被打，几乎被当成仆人使用。但对奥斯卡来说，没有人是容易被仇恨的。他的一生中，他一直敬仰着拉米雷斯·拉莫斯，那个他以为是他父亲的人。
I said it was very, very, very tough because he's still a hero for me.
我说那非常非常非常艰难，因为他对我来说依然是个英雄。
Oscar never really knew Ramirez Ramos since he died when Oscar was so young. But growing up, he heard amazing things about him. His family praised the guy all the time, how he was the first in his class at military school, how he rose through the ranks and was able to pay for his siblings' education. In the end, Oscar's actually grateful to the lieutenant. He may have stolen Oscar, but he also saved him. Some 200 people were killed at Dos Erres-- infants, the elderly, all of Oscar's siblings, his pregnant mother. "Imagine being taken out of that pile," Oscar says. "Why me?"
奥斯卡从来没真正了解拉米雷斯·拉莫斯，因为他在奥斯卡很小的时候就去世了。但在成长过程中，他听到了关于他的精彩故事。他的家人一直赞美那个人，比如他在军校成绩优异，他是如何升职的，以及他是如何支付他兄弟姐妹学费的。最后，奥斯卡其实很感激那位中尉。他可能偷走了奥斯卡，但他同时也救了他。多斯埃雷斯有200多人被杀——婴儿、老人，奥斯卡所有的兄弟姐妹，他怀孕的母亲。“想象一下从那堆尸体中被带走，”奥斯卡说，“为什么是我？”
We've tried to figure out why Oscar was taken. And the most plausible theory we've heard comes from Oscar's aunt. She told Sara that Ramirez Ramos wasn't married and he didn't have any children, and that his mother wanted a grand-kid. She kept asking him to give her one. So one day, he showed up saying, "This is my son. I had him with a woman I'm no longer with."
我们试图弄清楚为什么奥斯卡会被带走。我们听到的最合理的理论来自奥斯卡的姑妈。她告诉萨拉，拉米雷斯·拉莫斯没有结婚，也没有孩子，他的母亲想要个孙子。她一直在求他给她一个。所以有一天，他出现说：“这是我的儿子。我和一个我不在一起的女人生的。”
You had said to me last time we met that you wanted to know more about your dad.
你上次见到我时曾对我说，你想了解更多关于你父亲的事。
Yes.
是的。
While my producer, Brian Reed, and I were reporting this story, Oscar asked us if we could find out more about Ramirez Ramos, this man who chose him. So we did.
当我的制作人布莱恩·里德和我报道这个故事时，奥斯卡问我们能不能多了解一下拉米雷斯·拉莫斯，这个选择了他的男人。所以我们做了。
We've talked to a lot of people. And different people have said different things. There's some good stuff. There's some descriptions. And there's some bad stuff. What do you want to know from what we've learned?
我们和很多人谈过。不同的人说了不同的话。有一些好的方面。有一些描述。还有一些坏的东西。你想从我们学到的东西中了解什么？
All of it.
所有的东西。
You want to know everything?
你想了解一切？
I want to know it all, oh yeah. I want to know everything.
我想要了解一切，哦是的。我想要了解一切。
The bad stuff, some of it is going to be upsetting.
那些坏的东西，有些可能会让你不安。
That's OK. I want to know everything. It probably is not going to change the way that I think about him. But I want to know.
没关系。我想要了解一切。这可能不会改变我对他的看法。但我想要知道。
We told Oscar, sitting at his kitchen table. It was very difficult. Some of what Cesar and Favio said about Ramirez Ramos was positive. Soldiers looked up to him. They say they never saw him rape anyone.
我们在奥斯卡的餐桌旁告诉了他。那非常困难。塞萨尔和法比奥关于拉米雷斯·拉莫斯说的一些话是正面的。士兵们敬仰他。他们说从未见过他强奸任何人。
In fact, Cesar said Ramirez Ramos was angry about the rapes at Dos Erres. He heard him tell another lieutenant, "This is an attack unit, not a rape unit." We asked them if they ever saw Ramirez Ramos kill anyone. Cesar said, "No, the lieutenant spent much of the massacre overseeing the operation from a tree trunk with the other commanders." But Favio said yes, he definitely saw Ramirez Ramos kill people at the well.
事实上，塞萨尔说拉米雷斯·拉莫斯对多斯埃雷斯的强奸事件感到愤怒。他听他告诉另一名中尉，“这是一支攻击部队，不是强奸部队。”我们问他们是否看到过拉米雷斯·拉莫斯杀人。塞萨尔说，“没有，中尉在大部分屠杀过程中与其他指挥官在一根树干上监督行动。”但法比奥说是的，他确实看到拉米雷斯·拉莫斯在井边杀人。
He said the lieutenant was actually showing soldiers how to use the sledgehammer to murder people. "It's easy to give a blow to the head," Favio heard Ramirez Ramos say as he was demonstrating. Favio says this happened while Cesar was away guarding the perimeter, so Cesar didn't see it.
他说中尉其实是在向士兵展示如何用大锤谋杀。“给人头部一击很容易，”法比奥听到拉米雷斯·拉莫斯边示范边说。法比奥说这发生时塞萨尔不在，他在守卫外围，所以塞萨尔没看到。
We talked to a third person who knew Ramirez Ramos, a soldier who went to school with him and was stationed at a base with him before he became a Kaibil. The soldier said Ramirez Ramos had a reputation for being bloodthirsty, that he would dress as a civilian and go out in covert operations to capture people and torture them for intelligence.
我们和第三个认识拉米雷斯·拉莫斯的人谈过，一名和他一起上学并在此前驻扎在同一个基地的士兵。那名士兵说，拉米雷斯·拉莫斯有嗜血的名声，他会装扮成平民，出去执行秘密任务抓捕人并折磨他们以获取情报。
He called him "a crazy sadist," someone who took pleasure in hurting people. And that's basically what we've learned from the three people we talked to.
他称他为“疯狂的虐待狂”，一个以伤害人为乐的人。这基本上就是我们从我们谈过的三个人那里了解到的。
Obviously if you're in the army, at some point you ended up doing bad things, even if you don't want to. But killing, the killing, that's bad. But he wasn't bad with his family. He wasn't bad to me. He was my father for me. He was my father, you know?
显然如果你在军队里，在某些时候你最终会做坏事，即使你不愿意。但是杀人，杀戮，那是坏的。但他对他的家人不坏。他对我不坏。对我来说他是我的父亲。他是我的父亲，你知道吗？
In the summer of 2011, 16 years after Aura first found the bones in the well, a judge finally handed down a verdict in the case. Three Kaibiles and Lieutenant Carias, the local military commander who had threatened victims' families, were found guilty of murder during the Dos Erres massacre. The judge sentenced them to 6,060 years in prison-- 30 years for each confirmed victim, plus another 30 for crimes against humanity.
2011年夏天，奥拉在井中发现骨头16年后，一名法官最终就此案做出了判决。三名Kaibiles士兵和当地军事指挥官卡里亚斯中尉（他曾威胁过受害者的家人）被判在多斯埃雷斯屠杀案中犯有谋杀罪。法官判处他们6060年监禁——每名受害者30年，加上反人类罪判处30年。
This was unprecedented. It was the first time any member of the military was put away for a massacre they had committed during the war. Two months ago, Sara Romero's prosecution team did it again. One of the soldiers who was at Dos Erres was found living in California. He was sent back to Guatemala and also sentenced to 6,060 years.
这是前所未有的。这是第一次有军方成员因战争期间实施的屠杀被关进监狱。两个月前，萨拉·罗梅罗的起诉团队再次做到了。其中一名在多斯埃雷斯的士兵被发现在加利福尼亚州生活。他被遣返回危地马拉，同样被判处6060年监禁。
And even more incredible, just this week, the man who was the president of Guatemala during the massacre, Efrain Rios Montt, was indicted for genocide at Dos Erres. Now, there are half a dozen cases like Dos Erres moving forward in Guatemala. The climate in the country is changing. And some people worry about this new direction. First among them, this man.
更令人难以置信的是，就在本周，大屠杀期间危地马拉总统埃弗拉因·里奥斯·蒙特因多斯埃雷斯案被控种族灭绝。现在，危地马拉有半打像多斯埃雷斯这样的案件在推进。国家的氛围正在改变。一些人对这个新方向感到担忧。其中最首要的人就是这个人。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
The president of Guatemala, Otto Perez Molina. He took office five months ago. During the war, he did counter-insurgency. At one point, he was director of military intelligence. He also headed the School of the Kaibiles for a while. When Perez Molina was elected, there was concern that he might put an end to the Dos Erres case and investigations like it.
危地马拉总统奥托·佩雷斯·莫利纳（Otto Perez Molina）。他五个月前上任。战争期间，他从事反叛乱工作。一度，他是军事情报局局长。他还担任过一段时间的Kaibiles学校校长。当佩雷斯·莫利纳当选时，人们担心他可能会终止多斯埃雷斯案及类似调查。
He hasn't. He's letting them move forward. There's a lot of international pressure for him to do that. It's a precondition for the US to resume military aid.
他没有。他让它们推进。国际社会对此有很大的压力。这是美国恢复军事援助的前提。
But at the same time, he says publicly that seeking justice for crimes of the past is not the best way for Guatemala to move on. He told us that 16 years ago the Guatemalan Congress granted amnesty to most people who committed crimes during the war, so the war wouldn't continue in courts. He says trying these cases is counterproductive to reconciliation. It just stirs bad blood.
但与此同时，他公开表示，为过去的罪行寻求正义并不是危地马拉继续前进的最佳途径。他告诉我们，16年前危地马拉国会向大多数在战争期间犯下罪行的人给予了特赦，这样战争就不会在法庭上继续。他说审判这些案件对和解是适得其反的。这只会引起不和。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
Emblematic cases like Dos Erres should be known. But it's not the path or the route that Guatemala should follow. We Guatemalans should be able, on both sides, for the benefit, for the sake of the future generations, to find forgiveness and to look forward without stumbling upon the past at every moment.
像多斯埃雷斯这样的标志性案件应该被知道。但这并不是危地马拉应该遵循的路径或路线。我们危地马拉人应该能够在双方，为了利益，为了后代的缘故，找到宽恕并向前看，而不是时刻被过去所羁绊。
People involved in these cases are amazed at the changes now happening in Guatemala. And if you look back at Dos Erres, the Kaibiles made a few mistakes that allowed that case to be the first one of its kind-- mistakes that came back to haunt them 30 years later.
参与这些案件的人对危地马拉现在发生的变化感到惊讶。如果你回看多斯埃雷斯，Kaibiles犯了几个错误，使得该案成为同类案件中的第一个——这些错误在30年后回来困扰他们。
They let an 11-year-old escape, Salome, who testified against them. They abducted two boys, who later became living evidence linking specific soldiers in that unit back to Dos Erres. And probably the biggest mistake, they brought along a weak link, a guy who hadn't gone through all the intense Kaibil training, a cook who had flunked out and who, years later, couldn't stand the guilt and cracked.
他们放过了一个11岁的逃生者萨洛姆，他后来作证反对他们。他们绑架了两个男孩，后来成为了将那支部队中的特定士兵与多斯埃雷斯联系起来的活证据。可能最大的错误是，他们带上了一个薄弱环节，一个没有经过所有严格Kaibil训练的人，一个不及格的厨师，多年后无法忍受愧疚并崩溃了。
Without Favio, there would be no case. He and Cesar are still in witness protection.
没有法比奥，就不会有此案。他和塞萨尔仍在证人保护计划中。
As for Oscar, this coming Monday, he's doing something he almost never does-- he's taking the day off from work. He's got plans.
至于奥斯卡，下周一，他要做一件他几乎从不做的事——他要请假。他有计划了。
Next Monday, yes. Next Monday's going to be a big day for me. My father is coming over to the USA.
下周一，是的。下周一对我来说将是重要的一天。我的父亲要来美国了。
Tranquilino is getting on a plane with Fredy and Aura to come see Oscar for the first time since they were separated at Dos Erres.
特兰基利诺要和弗雷迪以及奥拉一起坐飞机来见奥斯卡，这是他们自多斯埃雷斯分开后的第一次。
Are you nervous?
你紧张吗？
Yes.
是的。
It's fair for Oscar to be nervous. His dad's visa allows him to stay with him for six months. There is a lot to talk about. Oscar has questions for Tranquilino. He wants to know what his mom looked like. He wants to hear about all his eight brothers and sisters. He talks to Tranquilino almost every day on the phone. But he still hasn't asked him any of that stuff. He doesn't even know basic things about his old life, like if he was the youngest of all the kids.
奥斯卡感到紧张是公平的。他父亲的签证允许他待六个月。有很多话要说。奥斯卡有疑问要问特兰基利诺。他想知道他母亲长什么样。他想听听他所有八个兄弟姐妹的事。他几乎每天都在电话里和特兰基利诺交谈。但他还没问过他那些事。他甚至不知道他过去生活的基本事情，比如他是否是所有孩子中最小的。
And there will probably be challenges. Tranquilino is old. He's never left Guatemala. He still drinks. Oscar works 80 hours a week, and his wife has four kids to take care of. They live in a two-bedroom house. But amazingly, Oscar's not focusing on that.
而且可能会有挑战。特兰基利诺年纪大了。他从未离开过危地马拉。他还喝酒。奥斯卡每周工作80小时，他的妻子要照顾四个孩子。他们住在一栋两居室的房子里。但令人惊讶的是，奥斯卡并没有关注这些。
I'm so happy to have him over. Everybody's so happy. So all that we need is a little bit more space.
我很高兴他能来。每个人都这么高兴。所以我们需要的就是多一点空间。
Where's he going to sleep?
他要睡在哪儿？
In my bed, I guess. Maybe the couch.
睡在我的床上，我想。也许是沙发。
You're going to give him your bed?
你要把你的床让给他？
Of course, yes.
当然，是的。
Where are you going to sleep?
你要睡哪儿？
The couch, maybe, or on the carpet. We have missed so much time. So we have a lot of time to spend together. We have to spend together a lot of time.
沙发，也许，或者地毯上。我们错过了太多时间。所以我们要花很多时间在一起。我们必须在一起待很长时间。
Habiba Nosheen, and Brian Reed, and their co-reporters for this story, Ana Arana and Sebastian Rotella, have a slide show and an even more detailed ebook version of this story at propublica.org. The ebook's also available at Amazon and at iBooks. It's called Finding Oscar . The story is also running in Spanish in a bunch of publications in Guatemala and throughout Latin America. There are links to all that stuff at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
哈比巴·诺欣、布莱恩·里德，以及他们在这个故事的共同报道者安娜·阿拉纳和塞巴斯蒂安·罗泰拉，在propublica.org上提供了这个故事的幻灯片和更详细的电子书版本。电子书也可以在亚马逊和iBooks上获得。书名叫《寻找奥斯卡》（Finding Oscar）。这个故事也在危地马拉和整个拉丁美洲的许多出版物上以西班牙语刊登。我们网站thisamericanlife.org上有所有这些资料的链接。
Our program and our story about Guatemala were produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollock, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Annie Correal helped with research and translations. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Production help from Matt Kilty. Music help from Damien Gray and Rob Geddis.
我们的节目和关于危地马拉的故事今天由布莱恩·里德制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·凯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦、丽莎·波洛克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。安妮·科雷尔协助研究和翻译。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。马特·基尔蒂提供了制作帮助。达米安·格雷和罗伯·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who stopped begging during the pledge drive so soon after he started.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责，他在认捐活动中还没开始多久就停止了乞求。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[西班牙语]
I just really only lasted about two weeks. My knees just couldn't take it.
我其实只坚持了两周。我的膝盖受不了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。